hundreds of lives in my hands where I  come from radio remains an important  means of transmitting news and  information and when I was young my  country was embroiled in many conflicts  the war with neighboring Somalia  traveled people most shortly before the  scorching Sun completed its journey  people would gather around radio  receivers it was my job to join one of  the largest radio sets so that everyone  in the town could listen chosen a  sickness I felt a real sense of pride in  making that possible  nothing has influenced my long career in  journalism and indeed in my life more  than the long evenings that I had as I  was a 12 year old by choosing this  career it has given me a way to transmit  that rose my name is Nagesh Minaj and I  wore at GW  you